welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the batman trailer released at
dc fandom reveals this younger bruce
wayne played by robert pattinson chasing
a zodiac inspired riddler through a
series of riddles and death traps all
intricately designed as an elaborate
plan that this bat is too blind to see
because he's vengeancing the crap out of
everyone the riddler calmly surrenders
himself to a gotham police which is
never a good sign and after he is in
lock-up batman screams
[Music]
translating to what have you done
implying getting arrested was part of
the riddler's jigsaw or 7-esque plan so
what is this riddler's endgame well
after breaking down this trailer frame
by frame a few shots continue to turn my
brain into a riddler cappuccino one
bruce's hand-sprayed concept map to
decode the riddler's plot in what looks
like an active crime scene where is this
two a folded piece of film with a very
un-ridley see you in hell written on it
three an overhead shot of batman leading
the police through some flooded area
where are they going and four alfred
reacting shocked to something on tv
what could make this help that's tough
as nails react that way really he's
probably reacting to the news report of
the riddler live streaming one of his
murders and that report labels ridler as
a serial killer so let's plug these
puzzle pieces into the timeline of the
murders based on the trailer clues that
we know of so the riddler's first kill
is gotham mayor don mitchell jr his
second kill is district attorney gil
coulson who is forced into crashing
mitchell's funeral armed with an
explosive that we know for sure
detonates and his third kill based on
bruce's concept map is police
commissioner peter savage who we see at
a press conference outside mitchell's
home after his death now in mitchell's
crime scene the riddler edward nashton
leaves a card addressed to the batman on
the cover of that card there's an owl
with a skeleton and a small bat framed
in the full moon and it reads from your
secret friend and the owl responds
the inscription side reads let's play a
game just me and you and ashton wrote on
the other side what does a liar do when
he's dead with a code made up of symbols
that we have translated to he lies still
now in addition to the overt parallels
to the real-life zodiac killer there is
enough in these clues pointing to the
court of owls from the batman comics the
shadowy cult that secretly runs gotham
city using an executioner called talon
there's the owl on the card the later
riddle references a court there's the
funeral portrait of the mayor wearing a
red lapel pin which in the comics was a
smoky gun clue that batman used to
deduce mayoral candidate lincoln
marsha's connection with his own family
and the court of owls but real quick
losing your hair at a young age is a
bummer two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35. now
sure nick fury makes the ball look cool
but in those 90s flashbacks he doesn't
have a full head of hair just going bald
can be stressful for the guys i know
going through it but with keeps it's
easier and more affordable to get
treatment for your hair loss and help
you keep the hair that you have keeps
offers generic versions of the only two
fda approved hair loss products out
there but at half the cost of your local
pharmacy though you'll never have to go
into a doctor's office with keeps you
get 24 7 access to a doctor who designs
the best plan for you they offer other
helpful tools and services including the
tracking tools so you can monitor your
progress find out why keeps has more
five star reviews than any of its
competitors and nearly 100 000 men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication so if you're ready to take
action to prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description to receive 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com new rockstars but he lies still
really points to the riddler's second
target mitchell's funeral here district
attorney gil coulson is duct taped with
a similar no more lies gag and a neck
bomb in another letter addressed to the
batman we don't see that card yet but
coulson has an iphone set to speaker
mode and an echoey voice from nashton
played over the first trailer that might
be the rhyming riddle inside the card if
you
are justice please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye
a riddle that i've suggested could point
to an answer like you get a head
pointing at the third target the number
three in command of gotham police
commissioner peter savage who could end
up decapitated and that third crime
scene could be the context in which
nashton's third riddle comes out
which would point to his next target
being at someone in the police force but
whoever this is i think at this point
the riddler allows himself to get caught
perhaps identified via his live stream
and when he gets caught in that diner he
slowly raises his hands but really just
his left hand as if he is asking a
question in a classroom and he could be
requesting to speak to the batman but
then after nashton's arrest a new detail
in that livestream video could reveal a
fourth target that he left alive in a
death trap a kind of jigsaw scenario and
if nashton would be working his way down
the police chain of command that would
leave chief mackenzie bach con o'neal's
character who's standing to the right of
savage at the press conference or maybe
barry killian's character officer
stanley merkel who we have not yet seen
any of the trailers or even the
runner-up of the mayoral race bella
rayal actually in the first trailer on
the screen in the bat cave appears to be
some woman who could be real and in the
shot of alfred saying dear god to the
left is the arm of bruce's writing
jacket so he is reacting to this news in
this moment too so now at this point
batman goes back to meet with nashton in
police custody i've been trying to reach
you
so i think this conversation leads
nashton to lure batman and the police to
this flooded area to rescue that fourth
target but inside batman discovers the
riddler's fourth riddle which is written
on this piece of film folded as if it
was in an envelope but it's simply just
an fu and so the black and blue and dead
all over target really was batman and
black and the police in blue both of
them dead all over when they are flooded
and drowned by batman as we see him
later covered in mud must survive it and
so then i think this leads batman to
realize he has been the true target of
the riddler's scheme
you'll see which brings us back to this
mystery location there is police tape
and if you brighten all this up the
columns the stone floor the indoor
outdoor structure they all seem like a
large mausoleum which is interesting
because other trailer footage shows
batman visiting a large cemetery and on
that octagonal table when you rotate it
upside down that looks like a shield
with a w inside of it the wayne family
crest this could be in the mausoleum
where bruce's parents thomas and martha
wayne are buried thus sins of my father
they are connected with this other
interesting tidbits by the way here
beneath that lamp near the word mitchell
looks like the riddler's military cold
weather mask so batman has really laid
out all the evidence here and then on
that cushioned seat in the upper left
two frames which could be the photos of
thomas and martha so i think the reason
police tape is stretched around this
location is that the wayne family plot
could have been vandalized or maybe even
the riddler used it as a scene of one of
its crimes like where savage was found
murdered and that could have been why
alfred seeing that on tv responded to
your god and now after riddler has
successfully flushed out most of the
police bruce could have returned here
and used this as his home base to figure
out his family's connection to riddler's
overall plot i think the wayne family
history is at the heart of this mystery
as i pointed out before the batman's
chest emblem in this movie looks like it
is components of a split handle of a
handgun perhaps the gun that joe chill
used to kill his parents and now the
riddler may be forcing bruce to reopen
the case of his own parents murders
something that he might learn was
actually a targeted assassination due to
thomas's sins like due to his membership
in the shadowy cult of the court of owls
which i have theorized before could be
continuing to manipulate this batman
vigilante as their talon style enforcer
while the corrupt police leadership of
the city turns a blind eye to the
batman's violent methods the words
renewal is a lie could be something the
riddler might have said that bruce now
interprets to mean that a city renewal
project is actually a chinatown-esque
infrastructure conspiracy masking the
court's insidious control over gotham so
what is the ripler's ultimate plan to
take out city leaders to expose the
corruption in gotham exposed the
batman's role in helping maintain that
status quo it exposed how his parents
were murdered to drive him into
street-level vigilantism that only helps
the city's true elites and bringing it
all to light by curing the world's
greatest detective of his own blind eye
let me know your thoughts on this theory
and you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching batman
[Music]
you